bonjour je m'appelle emmanuel de places
j'habite à cette ombre et j'ai 26 ans
j'ai le permis de conduire ainsi que le
véhicule je souhaite travailler à la
réunion ainsi qu'en métropole je
souhaite travailler en tant que
conseiller en insertion professionnelle
concernant ma formation j'ai un
baccalauréat stg comptabilité finance
d'entreprise titre manager dpm narration
une licence management commercial et une
licence formation accompagnement
concernant mon expérience
professionnelle j'ai travaillé dans un
supermarché en tant que vendeuse
charcuterie fromagerie ensuite j'ai
travaillé dans une restauration rapide
en tant que adjointe et lecture j'ai été
aussi auto entrepreneurs en meubles des
maisons produits d'entretien concernant
mme aloisia jamal au cinéma je fais
quelquefois les randonnées et fuit
chanteur j'ai notamment sorti un cd en
2012 pourquoi recruter je suis une
personne très zidane est très sociable
je mettais très rapidement à l'ensemble
de l'équipe j'ai pas peur d'aller de
l'avant de prendre des initiatives
vous pouvez m'appeler à n'importe quel
moment je suis à votre disposition à
bientôt